becky salisbury knows too well the
damage a ping can do to a business
the orford arms had barely reopened last
month when a positive covered test for
one employee
meant the rest had to self-isolate
closing the pub for 10 days
the impact was really quite severe just
the stock losses were
thousands of pounds the food alone was
two and a half three thousand pounds
with the stop losses
it was very difficult times we've worked
so hard to make some profit
after coming out of lockdown and then to
basically see it all washed
away again the test and trace app is
supposed to slow infection rates
but since social distancing rules were
dropped it's ground many businesses to a
halt too
under pressure the government has agreed
a change that will see the app look for
close
contacts of asymptomatic covert cases up
to 48 hours prior to their positive test
rather than the current five days what
we are doing in this new context
of opening up is to try and get the
balance right between the public health
advice
and the way people are living their
lives and the social and economic
factors affecting them
and so we are altering the logic of the
app which will mean that
uh fewer contacts will be contacted will
be advised to isolate
and that is because we will only be
contacting those at higher risk
where they have had very close contact
in the most infectious period
of the positive case the government say
only 40 percent of smartphone owners are
regularly using the app
despite this almost 690 000 orders to
self-isolate were sent in the week to
july 21st
a record but of those the government
assumed 40
won't comply food distributors
are already exempt from isolation if
they take daily tests instead
while this change will reduce the number
of pings other industries
say they should be ditched altogether
about six out of ten
of our workers who are pinged on the app
don't come into contact with
kobit haven't had a case and so are
still going to be caught by this
pandemic
so we do urge the government to continue
to work towards a workable self
isolation policy and a test to release
mechanism
in two weeks daily testing will replace
isolation for all
double vaccinated close contacts but
with those with single shots
still vulnerable to the app expect
pressure on government
to remain paul kelso sky news